ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de l'Enseignement
Privé j'ai bataillé durant des années
pour que l'école publique et laïque
donne à nos enfants à tous nos enfants
le meilleur de ce que la République peut
leur offrir mes combats je les ai mené
au côté des milliers d'autres parents
que vous avez méprisé insulté en
quelques
déclarations vous vous êtes simplement
moqué de ces élèves et de leurs parents
qui VO ch année des centaines d'heures
d'enseignement de mathématiques de
français ou de Langle disparaître en
prétendant avoir subi un paquet d'heures
non remplacé en petite section de
maternelle situé dans l'un des quartiers
les plus hupés de
Paris toutes ces militantes et tous ces
militants de l'école publique toutes
celles et ceux qui n'ont pas fait le
choix de la résocratie méritent mieux
alors vous vous qui esttes une partisane
du mérite sans vous soucier d'ailleurs
de ce qui relève du mérite de l'argent
ou du Mérite du talent je vous le
dis vous ne méritez plus d'être la
ministre de l'Éducation
nationale car si l'on en croit ce que
disait
Voltaire la politique c'est l'art de
mentir à propos manifestement vous vous
avez manqué d' propos donc ma question
madame la ministre de l'Enseignement
Privé est simple quand allez-vous clore
ce chapitre quand
démissionnerez-vous je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Amélie oua
Castera ministre de l'Éducation
Nationale de la Jeunesse des sports des
Jeux olympiques et
[Musique]
paralympiques madame madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député arénas à
peine nommé ministre de l'éducation
nationale j'ai été interpellé par miaap
part sur les choix de scolarisation de
mes enfants
j'ai voulu y répondre sans esquiver
l'attaque je l'ai fait avec sincérité
s'il vous plaît je n'aurais pas dû me
laisser entraîner sur le terrain de la
vie
privée ni me sentir obligé de me
justifier aucun parent d'élèves ne
devrait l'être et je n'aurais pas dû non
plus exposer l'école
litrée je suis allée à leur rencontre ce
matin pour m'en excuser et mexcuser de
les avoir blessé ces excuses je les leur
devais alors depuis vendredi j'ai tout
entendu les leçons de morale sur l'école
publique de la part de ceux qui mettent
leurs enfants dans l'école privée
l'agressivité de ceux qui rêveraient de
raviver une guerre entre l'école
publique et l'école privé guerre qui
n'existera pas et ce weekend c'est mes
valeurs éducatives de maman qui ont même
été mis en doute dans mes propos de
vendredi je me suis suis appuyé sur le
souvenir et le ressenti d'une expérience
d'il y a 15 ans où notre famille oui aé
sur des problèmes d'organisation comme
nous avons pu nous en souvenir avec
l'enseignante de l'époque avec qui j'ai
échangé alors maintenant avançons j'ai
de j'ai j'ai de l'ambition pour l'école
je veux soutenir toute la communauté
éducative pour remettre l'ascenseur
sociale en
et faire grandir le mérite et le talent
c'est le sens du choc des savoirs et de
l'exigence voulue par le Premier
ministre des concertations engagées pour
le métier de professeur ce matin j'ai
échangé avec les enseignants de l'IT sur
notre feuille de route pour l'école publ
et la problématique des remplacements
nous avons commencé à la traiter nous
irons jusqu'au bout car c'est un
problème que les Français des millions
de familles veulent que nous trations
c'est en ce sens que je ferai des
propositions au premier
ministreécole la mère des batailles et
je mesure l'honneur qui m fait de la
servir merci beaucoup madame la
ministre monsieur aras vous avez la
parole madame cette affaire que vous
avez mis sur la place publique n'est pas
une affaire privée c'est une affaire
publique qui remet en question le
fonctionnementme de l'éducation
nationale que manifestement vous
connaissez
pas entre les prop que vous avez ten en
tant ministre que mère de famille parce
que vous avez le droit de choisir
l'école que vous le souhaitez c'est la
loi qui vous d'autorise et les propos de
cette enseignante qui n'a pas manqué
d'ord de cours j'ai choisi mon camp
madame j'ai chis celle des enseignants
qui mettent plus que leur salaire pour
honorer le service public d'éducation
nationale je vous en prie allez chercher
l'argent privé que vous avez pour faire
en sorte que les Jeux Olympiques se
tiennent dansentrere pays et redonner à
l'éducation nationale ces lettres de
noblesse que vous avez abîmé en deux
déclarations merci
beaucoup